so the bartender says I don't know about
you guys Brian put on one of those hats
he was wearing one of those hats get it
no no I don't think we do oh come on you
guys are from Texas
well Tennessee actually Texas Tennessee
I got a cousin in Iowa it's all the same
you guys really didn't like that joke no
it was confusing I've done quite a few
Jews none of them have wings and even if
they did have wings that'd be pretty rad
just flying around eating matzo balls
while still also hating yourself I get
that yeah that sounds like a sweet can
Friday to me look we get it all right
the accents the Fox News level of anger
that we omit the cheap beer hops give me
gas but you think it's because we think
that fancy beer makes you gay you got a
drink liquor if you want a liquor that's
gross come on the point is just like how
not everyone with your accent wants to
beat his wife with a pepperoni stay you
know shout out to your cousin Tony and
all a great guy gets out in a year not
everyone with our accent is ignorant
yeah or wants to get rid of the blacks
likes rubbing buttered corn on their
belly we get the bill oh come on guys I
didn't get to tell you the one about how
Puerto Ricans can't tap dance
it's not just that it's offensive you're
not funny like even in the world of I
got a racist joke for you yours you're
just bad you like a little league racist
and yourself uncle's in the Klan but at
least he gets time and premises are
weird nobody's buying your logic man not
even you think about the Asians felt
forced maybe skip that one at the rally
next weekend John Vito look buddy you
should probably just stick to the
classics where you go branching out for
example the way they smell that's always
a big hit or women aren't safe around
them how they're allergic the possums
the point is we really don't appreciate
you assuming that that just because we
have these accents means we hate
minorities happen again
fancy beer makes you gay get rid of the
blacks let's think about Asian the way
they smile women are safe around them we
don't like minorities they only heard
the bad parts yeah we know we're going
here's all my money hope Confederate
bills are okay let's go Corey we're not
all bad people and we we know that Jews
don't have wings good you stay golden
pony tail I can't believe you had a
suicidal racist monsters yeah it was
horrible I was trying to tell them about
the blacks and how their lives matter
hockey's
you